[Musique]
nous avons devant nous une échéance qui
est celle de l'ouverture à la
concurrence des bus du réseau de la RATP
en petite couronne le 31 décembre 2024
c'est un enjeu considérable en nombre de
personnel de matériel de transfert il y
a 19000 chauffeurs sagit de réussir une
échéance qui est pas simple et donc
l'idée simplement par cette proposition
de loi c'est d'AM AG un certain nombre
de dispositions de se donner un petit
délai pour ne pas avoir tous les lots en
même temps 13 grands lots qui sont
chacun l'équivalent de la ville de Renn
et de permettre un échelonnement de
l'ouverture à la concurrence ça n'est
pas une privatisation c'est une
ouverture à la concurrence ce sont des
délégations de service public donc qui
vont être mises je dirais sur le marché
pour faire en sorte
que demain ben il n'y ait plus je dirais
un seul monopole c'est-à-dire la RATP
mais une multitude d'autres entre prise
qui pourrait répondre à la demande
d'île-de-fance mobilité pour demain nous
avons une obligation d'ouverture à la
concurrence c'est une obligation
européenne et en soi c'est un principe
qui est sain ça permet à l'autorité
concédante en l'occurrence île-defance
mobilité de se poser des questions sur
le service qu'elle attend sortir un peu
dans certainbre d'habitudes anciennes de
permettre de mettre des innovations dans
dans les procédure et ça permet
d'améliorer la qualité de service de
réfléchir aussi sur la de coûte parce
que lorsqu'il est mise en concurrence
ben on vérifie que le budget qui est mis
est celui qui est le le le plus
compétitif une ouverture à la
concurrence ça fait forcément peur au
salariés au syndicat à juste titre
d'ailleurs c'est un changement je dirais
de statut c'est quand même des 19000
personnes qui sont concernées c'est
important de rassurer l'ensemble des
salariés qui demain vont changer
d'entreprise quoi qu'il arrive nous les
parlementaires et au Sénat on tient
absolument à ce que les salariés sachent
vers quoi ils vont vers quoi ils vont
signer et qu'il n'y ait aucune perte je
dirais de salaire de prime et qu'il
puisse continuer à travailler dans des
conditions tout à fait
[Musique]
acceptable